venom let there be carnage features
plenty of instantly quotable lines that
mean much more than you might pick up on
the first time you see the film these
are the most important ones you may have
missed
this line is delivered by francis
barrison aka shriek in the film's
opening flashback as she informs her
demented boyfriend at same testis reform
school that she's being transferred to
ravencroft institute for the criminally
insane of course that boyfriend is
cletus cassidy and the line signifies
the realization that she'll likely spend
the rest of her days there being poked
prodded and otherwise rehabilitated with
no end in sight sure enough the film
picks up decades later with shriek
residing in a hannibal lecter meets
magneto glass prison cell to get
anywhere near her hospital aids must
wear specially made ear protection and
even then she still terrifies them in
the comics ravencraft provides an
environment where shriek is indeed
surrounded by others like her including
cletus who breaks her out and let there
be carnage however this line begins more
than 40 years of painful solitude so
it's no wonder that when carnage comes
to bust her out shriek is all too ready
to take a revenge field road trip
for much of the first venom movie we saw
eddie brock fighting the symbiote for
control of the body they shared in one
pivotal moment of the sequel the
audience sees how effective the two can
be when they work together after
visiting cletus cassidy behind bars
eddie begins thinking there might be
some clues amongst all the nonsensical
scribblings on his cell wall it is then
that venom unleashes a new power telling
eddie to put a sharpie in each hand and
then surrender control seconds later
eddie is drawing a perfect replication
of everything on those walls and venom
even uses his fingers to do an internet
search that turns up the location of
somebody's cletus was hiding from the
police like most of the movie a lot of
the sequence has played for laughs but
the bottom line is that with eddie's
body and venom's mind there isn't much
the two can't accomplish when they work
together
when eddie brock catches up with anne
his long-suffering ex it isn't
surprising that she still wants nothing
to do with him after all she's a
beautiful successful woman and he seems
to still spend every scene sweating
through a new t-shirt but with this
funny line michelle williams reminds the
audience that her character that's more
going for her than your average comic
book love interest like eddie she has
actually been venom she had a front row
seat for the adventure that almost
killed eddie and tries she might to
ignore them she still does have some
feelings for him at first ann seems to
believe eddie when he insists that venom
is no longer with him but and knows
eddie so she is soon speaking to venom
just as often as she's speaking to her
ex showing off a big engagement ring and
explains that she's getting married to
dr dan and the scene is worth the price
of admission just for venom's running
commentary in some ways venom is the
ultimate wingman he seems determined to
always have eddie's back because of the
best of friends or perhaps something
more
this is usually none of our business but
the movie does bring it up so is venom
gay in the club scene which clearly has
an lgbtq angle to it venom turns down
the advances of a woman then appears on
stage talking about getting over eddie
as if he's a bad ex-boyfriend whoever
thought venom could have a side hustle
as a motivational speaker considering
venom is a functionally gender fluid
character who reproduces through
non-sexual means does any of this really
matter outside of what it means for
venom's newfound confidence no it
doesn't matter at all
in a domestic dispute between eddie and
venom this line is the straw that breaks
the camel's back during their spat venom
and eddie wrestle break things and say
some things they seem to immediately
regret but it's just one line eddie
throws of venom diminishing his ability
to live or work independently that
finally pushes venom over the edge and
who's doing some serious couples
counseling within seconds venom is
packing his stuff and heading out into
the city alone could venom really manage
to lead a life of his own being a
responsible earthling with a steady 9-5
well probably not but eddie's real point
is one that's come up in domestic spots
for decades without me you're nothing
venom's immediate thoughts as he and
eddie visit cletus at san quentin state
prison about the place is an
all-you-can-eat buffet in the symbiote's
mind everyone in the prison is the
lowest of the low bad people who won't
be missed if venom has a light snack
it's been a while since he's been able
to chum down on a yummy human and
chickens and chocolate just aren't
cutting it anymore of course eddie
disagrees as evidenced by the rules no
eating people sign he made for venom in
their apartment the killer symbiote is
now on a diet of chocolate and chickens
and as much as he would like to chow
down on mrs chen or any of the inmates
at san quentin he's trying in his own
freaky way to honor eddie's wishes i
have tasted blood before and that is not
it this is cletus cassidy's reaction
when he takes a bite out of eddie brock
it feels like cletus are suspected for
some time likely all the way back to the
end of the first film that's something
supernatural is going on with eddie the
bite itself seems like a desperate
attempt to uncover that secret before he
dies it works because whatever cletus
tastes contains some tiny particle of
venom creating a spawn of the symbiotes
that takes over the serial killer's body
when that lethal injection opens up his
bloodstream not only does the line hint
at cletus being smart enough to sense
all this in eddie the first time they
met but woody harrison's line readings
at times like this also go a long way
harrelson has been harnessing his ah
shucks twang since his days on cheers
that mischievous twinkle in his eyes
since white men can't jump and a darker
homicidal side since natural-born
killers the role of cletus cassidy seems
to bring all three together in a way
that puts lines like this on a tee for
this beloved actor who is more than
ready to knock it out of the park
once i kill that thing that made me i'll
be indestructible this line spoken by
carnage sums up the creature's
motivation carnage wants venom invited
to the so-called red wedding between
cletus and shriek because the red
symbiote smartly realizes that the only
being that can approach him in power is
venom venom also seems to realize that
carnage could likely take him down
because when he first lays eyes on
carnage he retreats back into eddie in
fear but ultimately venom seems to
realize that he and eddie are the only
ones who can stop this thing setting up
an inevitable final smackdown between
father and son
after cletus infiltrates ravencraft and
reintroduces himself to the woman he
pledged his love to shriek's unusual
reaction is to be pretty turned on in
the scene cletus at first seems almost
apologetic he has changed substantially
and needs to explain his new alien
friend to the woman he loves after
asking her to not freak out cletus tells
shriek i want you to meet carnage
sounding like a proud southern boy who's
just brought home a puppy
instead of freaking out about the truly
insane addition to cletus's anatomy
shriek simply replies that is so hot in
no time the two of them are off on a
killing spree just two crazy kids in
love the message is that she accepts
cletus just as he is in a world where no
one else will
shriek's most prominent superpower is
the ability to emit piercing brain
scrambling auditory attacks not exactly
the thing you want around a symbiote
sensitive to nothing but fire and sound
as this becomes clear cletus seems to
make a choice carnage over shriek
although he does still go through with
the red wedding watch those scenes again
and you might notice cletus slowly
retreating from shriek much like the way
his physical body is retreating inside
carnage by screaming at shriek telling
her not to kill his new friend cletus
sacrifices the one person in the world
who loved him for what he was by the
time she meets her death cletus barely
seems to care
a lot was made out of poor kia sin
dunn's perpetual status under some rainy
spider-man movies as a plot driving
object to be bound gagged and dangled
off some high perch by an evil villain
but that was more than a decade ago
right we've all come so far and michelle
williams is an oscar-winning actor who
surely wouldn't sign up for such a thing
right
nope in one of the few disappointments
in the film williams and is reduced to
helpless status in the third act when
shriek says hello to her and says she's
just incapacitated her boyfriend it
indicates a pivotal moment when anne
goes from a complex confident character
who has twice been imbued with the power
of she venom to just another damsel in
distress waiting to be rescued
in the comic books carnage has a
tendency to call venom his daddy it's
kind of weird but he has a point let
there be carnage pays tribute to that
and reminds the audience of the stakes
by including this line in the scene when
venom and carnage finally go toe-to-toe
in the church he calls them father
several times during the scene to the
extent that you half expect them to call
the whole thing off and settle their
differences with a catch
dad
you wanna have a catch
oh yeah
unfortunately the way symbiotes work is
that every generation is considerably
more powerful than the one before it as
impressive as venom may have been in the
first movie his bizarre little offspring
is the latest model of iphone versus
venom's ipod shuffle in other words
calling venom further is not some mere
family reunion it's also a non-too
subtle message to venom that the time
has come for a new generation to rise
and replace the old
this line is delivered by cletus cassidy
during his final moments in the film
revealing an extra dimension of
complexity to his character all cletus
wanted to be it seems as eddie's friend
but eddie wants a story not a drinking
buddy so he has tried his best to keep
cassidy at arm's length so when cletus
gets daddy to snap in prison perhaps
he's comparing their violent histories
and body counts not to drive eddie crazy
but to find common ground when he
decided to give the reporter all those
interviews perhaps it was to create a
biographer type bond like writer truman
capote and the killer perry smith rather
than simply wanting to destroy eddie and
venom venom fans will likely never get
more of an answer to these questions
responding to him and the way he's
treated eddie venom dispatches him with
three simple words
this guy
so where does it all go from here well
the mid-credits scene gives you some
idea of the carnage connection across
universes to the mcu and spider-man and
other clues might even possibly allude
to the upcoming third movie in sony's
spider-man universe morbius the living
vampire but the line together we are the
lethal protector says quite a bit about
where things are going as well at the
end of the venom sequel eddie brock and
venom are finally on the same page to
discuss their potential together as
crime fighters it's an explicit shout
out to the comic book series venom
lethal protector the 1993 comic
storyline that considerably deepened the
lore behind venom as a character and
anti-hero finally at peace they're too
disgustful they'll go from here when
venom wonders if they'll need a cape and
mask eddie replies no i think you've got
that covered check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies and tv
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and to the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you